A common unspoken rule of commander is that people
should get to have a gameplan, to do a thing,
to do their thing. And on the surface, this makes
a lot of sense. It’s a casual format, people are
just here to have fun. In other casual multiplayer
games, universal participation is understood to be
a core tenet, and steps are taken to ensure that
all players get to play a part. In a roleplaying
game like D&D or Pathfinder, you don’t want to let
a player be a Wizard only to then have them spend
the entire campaign in places with some mysterious
anti-magic field. That’s not ideal gameplay! So
broadly, it’s understandable that commander echoes
this understanding, and even allows players 100
cards worth of expression in how they play the
game. This is all fine and good, but what’s easy
to forget is that commander is a multiplayer
offshoot of a generally two player game, an
offshoot that didn’t always exist. The fact that
the format has a higher life total than 60 card
1v1 formats is intentional—it works to make space
for decks that would otherwise struggle. There are
a lot of potential creative strategies that simply
can’t hold up in a 20 health format—attacking
people with creatures early is just a bit too
good. In this way, commander’s 40 starting
health itself serves as a built-in do-the-thing
enabler—no extra effort needed from players. This
higher life total was intended to accomplish
a task, and it did so admirably. However,
over time it has accomplished a lot more than
just this. I’m getting ahead of myself, though.
Commander has basically grown up with this
identity of being a slower format where a
more laid-back form of magic can be played.
This is reflected in the mana curves of a lot
of the original precons—zany, high cost
stuff is a staple feature of the format,
and these sorts of cards are often core pillars
in their respective decks. There are a couple
frameworks we could use to think about how
EDH decks compare to decks in a 60 card,
20 health format. One is the “turning point” of
a given game—basically, if we separate each game
into a buildup phase where players are preparing
and a climax phase where players are starting to
perform whatever action will win them the game,
roughly when is there a transition? In a lot of
classic 60 card decks this turning point is quite
early—Delver decks look to land a turn 1 threat
and gradually chip down opponents, and other
decks like Jund similarly look to land early
threats. In contrast to this, most commander decks
spend the first several turns of the game ramping,
setting up engines, tutoring, and starting to
piece together synergy packages. A big piece
of this likely comes down to life totals. 40 life
means that a threat needs to be larger to pose a
risk to opponents—whereas in Legacy a single mana
can be spent on a deck’s win plan followed by a
long sequence of turns purely spent defending
that plan and suppressing a player’s opponent,
a much larger mana investment is necessary
to break through 40 life without the help of
an infinite combo. In addition, even
if a deck defeats a single opponent,
there are two opponents still at the table, so
it’s often wise to invest an even greater amount
of mana upfront to formulate a threat that can
subdue two or more players in rapid succession.
The fact that larger investments are needed to
win games means that draw and ramp are almost
necessities—plans will involve lots of cards
that don’t directly contribute to winning a
game. This is another point of contrast between
commander and 60 card 1v1 formats—in a burn deck,
an ever-popular archetype in 60-card formats, a
majority of a deck will often be spent on the task
of reducing opposing life totals. Though you could
point to control decks as spending less deck space
on direct wincons, these decks still use cards
like removal and draw to build up to the dominant
gamestate they need to be in to win. A Lava Spike
performs a similar role for an aggro deck as an Up
the Beanstalk does for a control deck, and this
comes down to the fact that different decks are
different. If we focus on ramp, removal, and draw
as categories of card, a large portion of decks
in 60 card formats exclude one, two, or even all
three of these things, which is notable when you
consider that basically all commander decks are
expected to have all of these things. This is also
in spite of the fact that commander decks have
access to, well, a commander—an additional card
that is available at all times, a permanent eighth
card in hand. A lot of people fail to acknowledge
how incredible that is—a deck could easily pick
out a commander that mostly fulfills a particular
role to allow their deck to focus less on that.
But this isn’t generally what happens—taking a
look at some popular recent commanders, it’s
mostly payoff or escalation of some kind—when
a thing happens, either more of that thing or
something different happens. A lot of commanders
will draw cards in some form or other, but these
decks will then still include a lot of card draw.
These features paint a specific picture of
commander as a format. Decks are expected to
run decent quantities of ramp and draw because
they’re expected to be bigger, taller than decks
in 60 card formats, and this is facilitated by
having more cards and more mana. This much is
unsurprising—on some level these attributes are
encoded into the very DNA of the format. However,
over time this DNA has twisted and metastasized
into an increasingly homogenous version of the
format, one where decks are “expected” to look a
certain way. Decks have grown bigger and taller
over time—they gain more mana and draw more cards
than decks in the past did. The funny thing about
ramp and draw is that they have an amplifying
effect—while a wincon or a removal spell won’t
generate more of those things, ramp gives mana
to cast more ramp spells, and card draw finds
more card draw. As more and more powerful draw
engines have been printed over the last 10 years,
along with EDH developing a more streamlined
deckbuilding culture, decks that focus heavily on
draw and ramp have become more and more prevalent.
In tandem with this, deviance from this version of
commander has become increasingly challenging from
a social standpoint. When players see opponents
doing some sort of tall gameplan, one deckbuilding
reaction could be to go under it. This is common
in competitive 1v1 formats—you play aggro to rip
away your opponent’s life total while they’re
still in the setup phase of their greedy nonsense,
you play combo to take advantage of them ignoring
you, and you play stax pieces to clamp down on
specific play patterns. All of this is possible
in some form or other in commander—you can play
voltron or group slug, you can play combo, and you
can play stax pieces. The issue is, these things
are often considered rude at a lot of mid-power
EDH tables—it’s uncouth to see your opponent doing
some greedy nonsense and to then try to cramp down
on it. The polite counterplay is to go bigger—to
get more mana and more cards and escalate harder.
Commander as a casual format has the awkward
dynamic that there isn’t a metagame per-se,
and everything that happens is basically
moderated by a giant glob of expectations
that players and their opponents decide
on, verbally or otherwise. While certain
plays might not be explicitly disallowed, there
will be varying levels of social acceptance of
various different options a player could
decide on. These social pressures then
reinforce themselves as different players enter
and exit the format under these new conditions—if
a player base decides that Armageddon is
unacceptable, well Winter Orb is almost as bad,
and Gaddock Teeg is a bit too staxy as well, and
Archon of Emeria also constricts player agency,
doesn’t it? And I dunno about poison
counters and commander damage either,
those seem pretty sus as well. As countermeasures
become less and less widespread, players will feel
more and more emboldened to chase big, greedy
decks to their logical endpoint. As snowbally
midrange decks are allowed to become a more
and more dominant part of the EDH landscape,
they become all but synonymous with the format.
They become the way to play casual commander.
Now, I don’t want to necessarily say that this
is inherently a purely bad thing. I have multiple
decks that are absurdly tall or absurdly greedy,
and I’ve also made decks with the explicit intent
of being taller than other decks. The dominance
of tall commander means that players are able to
do big, expressive plays with a wide degree of
freedom. It means that new players are allowed
to explore the format without getting immediately
pressured down by decks built with the intent to
kneecap slower and greedier decks. Any given
deck’s “thing” may take more or less time
than any other deck’s “thing”, and allowing
the most of these things to happen involves
pushing back the point at which decks begin
to focus on closing out games, letting decks
focus more on the buildup stage. If the goal
is to accommodate the most of those and allow
the most people to do the most of their thing,
tall EDH is really the only way to go. However,
it’s also worth keeping in mind that this form
of commander isn’t without issues all of its own.
One issue with the gradual upward race of tall
commander is something I spent an entire 20
minute video on a couple months ago: information
overload. EDH boards are wildly complex these
days—while 60 card 1v1 formats feature the
relatively simple boardstate of two players,
EDH features the boardstates of four
players, boardstates that are often
far more complex than ones that would be
found in 60 card formats. As a result,
players in a game of commander need to process a
lot more different cards than players in a 60 card
format, and doing so will use mental energy that
could be spent on planning turns, strategizing,
politicking, or performing alternative forms
of threat analysis. This will naturally fall
hardest on newer players, who are familiar with
fewer cards and thus need to take more time to
process the cards being played in a game. Some of
this added information is inherent to commander
as a format. Having four players is kinda
baked into how we do things here in EDH-ville,
and having a massive thirty-year-long card
pool is lifewise a fact of life. Commander
is unavoidably going to be more complicated
than 60 card formats and that’s just kind of
the price of entry—it was originally popularized
by judges after all. What’s not a fact of life is
everybody playing these big, escalatory midrange
piles, with each deck developing more and more
utility or value permanents over the course
of the game, each with probably way too much
text. Commander is inherently complex,
but it doesn’t need to be this complex.
Big complex boardstates, paired with decks that
want to perform exponentially more actions as a
game progresses, lead to an additional
problem—turn lengths. Casual EDH games
have a reputation for being mercilessly long at
times, and I’d argue a lion’s share of this is
due to long turns. Long games aren’t always a bad
thing—I’ve had multi-hour back-and-forth grinds
that were genuinely exciting. However, when turn
length is the primary cause of a game’s length,
things are rarely this enjoyable. One of the
issues is that long turns beget long turns—if the
game’s turns are a sequence of back to back 5-10
minute fiddle fests, other people are going to
start chatting or checking their phone or gazing
off into space. Then, when it does get back around
to somebody’s turn, instead of planning ahead for
it their mind has been wandering, and they need to
recalibrate on what they’ll be doing, increasing
how long their turn takes. This cycle reminds me
of some of the less pleasant D&D encounters I’ve
partaken in, and it’s a cycle that can really
take a toll on the goal of maintaining a dynamic
game of EDH. The issue of long turns—and thereby
long games—then ends up decreasing the social
acceptability of more aggressive strategies. This
pattern is most clear with Voltron, an archetype
that involves putting a bunch of auras or
equipments on a particular creature and defeating
opponents with it one by one, but it really
applies to focusing down opponents in general.
Despite the fact that strategically it might be
correct to fully focus down a particularly scary
player, this is somewhat unpopular in part because
of how long EDH games go. If knocking out a player
meant them sitting around for 10 or 20 minutes for
the game to finish, I doubt most people would
have too big of an issue with that. However,
when it means sitting around for 45 minutes
or even an hour while the remaining players
fiddle around with their fussy boards of
snowball midrange, it’s a bit less ideal.
In addition to the other issues I’ve mentioned,
the current commander landscape is one that
favors board wipes quite heavily. Players
will put together these wild snowbally packages
that explode out of control in a matter of turns,
and when there are multiple of these sorts
of decks with taboos against stax and aggro,
the only only option is to board wipe, and
to board wipe frequently. The collateral
damage of this will be the players trying
to advance their gameplan at a normal pace,
trying to gradually build up something of their
own. This is the paradox of “doing the thing”—the
form of commander that gives players the most
time to develop a slower gameplan is the exact
same form of commander that cultivates board
wipes as this constant and unavoidable factor.
You get to do the thing, and I sure hope you
liked doing that thing because you’re gonna
get about five more chances to do it over again
after getting boardwiped. Me and my friend Hans
had an interesting conversation about board wipes
a few days ago, and it gave me some ideas that
I’ll probably throw into a little facecam video
that’ll go up on my Patreon in a couple days.
So those are some of my problems with the state of
commander as it currently exists—this wildly tall
version of the format—, and a natural followup
question might be “can those problems be solved in
a way that improves the format?.” I mentioned the
taboos against shorter strategies such as aggro
and stax, and I know some of you probably thought
to yourselves—”but Alex, even without taboos,
aggro simply isn’t a viable strategy in
casual commander.” Is this true? Kind of yes,
but also kind of no. It’s true in the sense
that if you pull out an aggro deck against three
snowbally midrange decks, the table will likely
get annoyed at you and beat you into submission.
It’s almost considered rude at a lot of EDH
tables to introduce life total into the game
as a relevant factor before people have generated
a bunch of value in whatever way their particular
deck likes to do such a thing. However, the fact
that games so often involve nothing but snowbally
value decks isn’t some kind of set in stone fact
of life. A good counter-example to the current
state of commander is a pool of $25 decks I played
with a few years back. That pool had some pretty
tall decks—a Simic toolbox midrange deck and
a Gruul big mana deck come to mind. However,
the tallness of these decks was modulated by the
diversity of the rest of the pool. The pool had
four faster decks that would put on pressure,
as well as a couple control decks that could
punish overextensions from any other deck. The
result of this was that all slower decks needed
to build in tools to hold off aggro—blockers,
lifegain, early removal, and so on. Likewise,
all of the midrange decks in the pool needed
to include tools for maintaining a gameplan
through the unrelenting grasp of the pool’s
control decks. This little metagame resulted
in well-rounded and resilient decks—when the
situations a deck is likely to end up in are
more specific and dramatic than simply facing a
squishy blob of generic midrange, those decks need
to be built in a way that adapts to that rather
than just following a formulaic plan every game.
The other thing this pool did was guarantee deck
diversity in games, since decks were selected
randomly from a pool of 10. The average 4-pod
deck pool would have two faster midrange decks,
one slower midrange deck, and one control deck.
Even in games where slower decks were represented
more heavily, a singular faster deck in the
pod could usually still do just fine—the slower
decks were somewhat diverse, and none of them were
all-in on a snowbally game plan because doing this
would likely lead to getting destroyed in any game
with more than one fast deck. The randomization
also had the side benefit of forcing players into
playing all decks and experiencing all sides of
things, which gave greater insight into how to
play strategically. Something funny is that the
Gruul big mana deck, the greediest deck in the
pool and decidedly mid-pack in terms of winrate,
ended up feeling the strongest outside of the
pool. Its weakness within the pool was other decks
pressuring it down knowing it would pop off in the
late game, but in the general commander ecosystem
people play slower decks and don’t have the same
built-in understanding that a late-game deck is
one that should be attacked early and often. It’s
rude to throw your creatures at the snowballiest
opponent turn after turn—you’d better spread
out that damage, they’re just trying to do
their thing after all. If you want to
hear more about this specific dynamic,
my friend The Trinket Mage just released
a video that dives into the question of
whether to allow decks to do their thing, and
a link to his video is in the description.
Now, does any of this information provide a
solution to the issues I have with tall decks?
Well, not exactly, but it’s a useful window into
how formats get conceptualized by the people who
play them. I’d encourage players to give building
their own deck pool a try, as navigating a little
metagame can be a lot of fun and is a type of
fun that commander players usually miss out
on. However, most commander games will continue
to feature unpredictable combinations of decks.
Likewise, having decks that deviate from
the snowball midrange mold can be quite fun,
but generally you need at least two deviating
decks in a game to really break out of the
conventional mold. For my part, I’m in my aggro
era—over the summer I revamped my Liesa hatebears
deck to have a bit less stax and some additional
tools for beatdown and value generation,
and it’s been a lot of fun to be threatening life
totals more consistently. I’m also tinkering with
a handful of other decks that can put on a healthy
amount of pressure while still fitting nicely
into a typical EDH game, including an update
of the Malfegor deck from the $25 deck pool.
Obviously you shouldn’t make it a goal to ruin
the fun of other players—some players do this,
and they should stop—but I’d argue it’s perfectly
fine to at least push other players out of their
comfort zone a bit. EDH is a game, not an
art palette or a drawing cards simulator,
and though the increased 40 life is nice for
allowing a greater diversity of slower decks,
it’s also valid to treat opposing life totals the
way they’re treated in other formats—a thing that
wins you the game if you reduce it to zero. There
is no one right answer to how to navigate a social
format like EDH, and people should largely be
allowed to play what they wanna play. We should,
however, give faster and more suppressive decks
at least a portion of the leeway given to the
synergy blobs of the world. A more vibrant
and dynamic format is a thing worth pursuing.
Thanks for watching! And thank you to Archidekt
for supporting the channel. I’ve been using
Archidekt for years, and the UI is so crisp and
neat-looking that I’ve used screenshots from
Archidekt in videos going back months before they
were even giving me money. You can check out all
my decks at the link down in the description.
I also want to thank my Patrons for supporting
the channel, and if you want to join them you
can do so over at patreon.com/SalubriousSnail.
Finally, if you want to pick up some cards for
that new stax deck you just got inspired to build,
I left a TCGPlayer affiliate link down in
the description. I’ve found TCGPlayer to
be the best place out there for buying lots
of cheap cards in one fell swoop, which has
been helpful over the years for all the budget
decks I’ve bought. Alright, that’s all. Bye now.